Speaker 1: We want to continue our discussion
about this whole mental health idea. We don't
need to deal with guns. We just need to deal with
mental health. Well, then it would follow that we
need to actually make mental health treatment more
accessible. Last week, we looked at Republican
Texas Congressman Tony Gonzalez, and I played
clips for you of Tony Gonzalez saying this is
just a mental illness problem, these shootings.
It's not about guns, it's just about mental
illness. That's all that we really have to deal
with. And then we looked at Tony Gonzalez, his
voting record when it came to increased access to
health care. And it was atrocious voting against
Obamacare expansions, voting against all sorts
of different funding for health related programs,
because it's just something they want to say.
It's not actually something they want to deal
with. Well, now we have an example of Republican
Texas Governor Greg Abbott. At a press conference
last week, Greg Abbott again said the issue
here, it's not about guns, it's about mental
health. Here is Greg Abbott explaining this.
Speaker 2: So the the ability of an 18 year old to
buy a long gun has been in place in the
state of Texas for more than 60 years.
And think about during the time
over the course of 60 years,
we have not had episodes like this.
Speaker 1: Now. Texas actually has a pretty big
mass shooting problem. But one of the things that
has changed, even if they want to make the case,
well, the access to guns hasn't necessarily
changed in the last six years. The marketing
to people to get more and more guns has changed
over 60 years. But importantly, the culture
around guns has changed over 60 years, where
because of this corrosive American gun culture
and the educational problems and the almost of the
delusional nature of the American right, more and
more people come to see firearms as a way to solve
problems. That's a cultural issue. So things have
changed. But now we're getting to the key part.
Speaker 2: And why why is it that for the
majority of those 60 years we
did not have school shootings?
And why is it that we do now? The reality
is I don't know the answer to that question.
However, what I do know in talking to the leaders
here, as well as leaders in other locations around
the state, and that is one thing that has
substantially changed is the status of mental
health in our communities. What I do know is this,
and that is we as a state, we as a society need
to do a better job with mental health. Anybody
who shoots somebody else has a mental health
challenge, period. We we as a government need to
find a way to target that mental health challenge.
Speaker 1: Right now, the issue with all of
this is, as usual, there is massive hypocrisy.
Greg Abbott cut 211 $11 million from a mental
health commission. There's a report on KSAT
which says Abbott has doubled down on his stance
that mass shootings are an issue of mental health
and not gun access. However, in April,
Abbott slashed nearly $211 million
from the Health and Human Services Commission,
which oversees mental health services in Texas.
Abbott diverted the funds to add to his effort
to send National Guard to the Texas-Mexico
border known as Operation Lone Star. No other
Texas agency received a more significant cut
than the HHC when Abbott slashed funding. Texas
ranks 44th in the United States for an overall
ranking of mental health measures and last out
of all 50 states in access to mental health care.
The Republican right never pays a political
price for their hypocrisy, and that has to
change. But think about the absurdity of this.
The problem isn't guns, it's mental health.
Well, okay. I mean, to a degree, we've been
talking about the problems there for a long time.
Although there's a cultural problem as
well, we got to figure out how to deal
with mental health. Oh, well, how would
we do that? I don't know. I cut funding
to expand mental health care in my state, which is
already dead last on access to mental health care.
To instead use the money to send National Guard
to the Texas-Mexico border. That's Vietnam. And
of course, unless their constituents are able
to follow and understand and be aware of this,
there's not going to be any accountability. There
simply isn't. It's you. It's not a crazy thing to
think a voter could understand. Okay, let's see.
Maybe guns are part of it, maybe they aren't.
But if mental health care is a part of it,
then what is Greg Abbott doing to deal with
that? Actually he's making the problem worse by
defunding it to send National Guard to the border.
Oh, I should vote against him. I should vote for
Beto O'Rourke. I should. You know what? Stay home.
But I shouldn't go and vote for Greg Abbott if
that's the case. But they don't hold themselves
to the standards which they appear to try to
hold the left to. And at this point, conservatism
fundamentally is about their are in groups. And
there are outgroups and it doesn't matter what
aspect of our politics we're talking about.
We must protect the end groups at all costs,
at the expense of the outgroups, even if we are
openly hypocritical. Openly hypocritical. Well,
it when it comes to immigration. Well, we must
protect the in-group, which is the natural born
American citizens or whatever. When it comes to
religion, the in-group is Christians. When it
comes to you understand the idea here and whatever
principle they state is going to be ignored when
it would no longer protect whatever the in-group
is at the time. And mental health now is the
issue in order to protect the gun owners and not
have to do anything about the guns. But we're not
actually going to deal with the mental health
issue. When we have opportunities to fund it,
we take money away. Don't you dare use my tax
money to help solve that problem. We're pro-life,
right? But don't you dare use my tax money to
improve foster care or to help single mothers, or
to fund comprehensive sex education, which reduces
the demand for abortions. No, no, no, no, no.
This is a sickness. I mean, listen, even look
at police, right? Oh, police are always right.
And we must support them always. When there's some
police use of force against, often it's a nonwhite
person, but then all of a sudden, well, look at
what happened. Look at how the police were treated
on January six. No, no, no, no. Now the police
are bad and the justice system is bad because the
in-group, the Trumpists are sitting in pretrial
detention. It's there are no actual principles
that go beyond supporting the in-group.
And we are very much seeing that here.